[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
we're breaking down lots of major
Spider-Man news not only do we have big
announcements or movie castings but I
also have some stuff I've heard to tell
you about how Andrew and Toby are
returning in this video we're going to
be breaking it all down but don't be a
spider Menace make sure you hit the
Thumbs Up Button like your Gwen Stacy
and it's a concrete floor also Subs
sorry guys about that we'll move on and
I'll get right into it
[Music]
now Spiderman no way home ended with
Toby and Andrew returning to their
respective universes and though that was
apparently the last of them I've heard
from my sources that they've been in
talks with Sony to return Andrew's
probably gonna deny it until the day he
dies oh [ __ ] here we go again but they
are apparently planning on having him
and Toby come back in smaller roles now
that the Multiverse is open this will
include voice appearances in across the
spider-verse this isn't my scoop and
huge it adds to Emerald Maine for
posting that Andrew and Toby will be
appearing in the movie as their own
Spider-Man that film is set to follow
miles as he travels across the
spider-verse and it'll include several
different versions of the character
popping up in the film Daniel kaluya has
also been announced as voicing spider
punk in the film and there are rumors
floating around that Tom Holland will be
appearing too no idea which version of
Spider-Man he's playing because because
we never found out who's beneath the
mask in the MCU however he will appear
alongside Haley Steinfeld Oscar Isaac
and also SRA as Spider-Woman there's
also apparently going to be appearances
from the Animated Series Spider-Man from
the 90s and also the Spider-Man from the
PS4 game Sony obviously saw how big that
Noe home was and realizing that they
have a ton of Spider-Man to pull from
they're apparently going to be filling
the film with every mainstream version
that we've ever had the formula for
comic book movies at the moment seems to
just be to get them all back and Sonia
doing this with their own spider verse
now I have heard that pretty much every
upcoming spider-verse film released by
Sony will tie into the other film so
that they become a sea the deal that
they brokered with Marvel Studios
allowed for Venom to stop by the MCU and
we of course also had vulture in the
best post-credits scene of all time
what
bro what are you talking about man have
you ever mentioned people like Hayley
Oscar and this uh they're gonna be the
main cast with Andrew Toby and Tom being
used more as cool cameos however Toby
and Andrew appearing here will very much
set the groundwork for things going
forward and from what I've been told
they'll be dropping in secret Wars 2.
according to my sources Kevin feigue
wants to have this as the biggest movie
of all time with almost every major
character from every major Marvel film
returning in some capacity from what
I've been told feige's dream and his
vision is to have a similar scene to the
portal Swan at the end of Avengers end
game however instead of just being
restricted to MCU characters we'll have
multiple Marvel franchises converging at
this point this will include turbine
Andrew Hugh Jackman is Wolverine several
X-Men cast members Fantastic Four ones
and so on and so forth Kang will have
ravaged multiple Dimensions at this
point and it'll be a final stand against
him across the entire Multiverse whether
this happens or not remains to be seen
and if they manage to bring back Wesley
Snipes his blade I'm gonna go mental in
the theater get him back
that's kind of obvious that that's a
type of thing they'd be planning for a
big multiversal movie but my source who
told me has got a number of things right
in the past whether it's them making an
educated guess or whatever it remains to
be seen but this is apparently the
quote-unquote end game of Kevin foggy's
plans I think it would be amazing if
they pull this off for like three weeks
obviously and then everyone can go back
to complaining about Marvel but those
three weeks it would be the best time of
our lives now in case you don't know the
ending of Secret Wars in the comics
caused several of the timelines to merge
into the main one characters like Miles
Morales had previously been apart from
the universe but he was brought in along
with others that Marvel wanted in the
616. from what I've heard this will be
similar to what Marvel wants to do with
the MCU with the ending of Secret Wars
allowing them to pick and choose
characters this includes certain ones
from the X-Men and with Patrick Stewart
and Ian McAllen probably getting to the
point where Marvel don't basically want
to build an entire franchise off the
back of them they can bring in people
like the the first class crew AKA
Fastbender and McAvoy now in order for
all this to happen with the Spider-Man
Spider-Man 4 needs to come first
according to Cosmic circus there's
discussions going on at the moment over
when it will be released with the aim
being that it's a 2024 movie this would
put it at the end of phase five and
there were rumors that it would release
July 12th that would mean it's coming
out two weeks before the Thunderbolts
which I personally I can't really see
that happening I think it's too close
and that one of the studios will have to
budge to give the other room to breathe
now as for the plot details from all the
rumors going around on this it won't
actually build off the tears at the end
of no way home that had Eddie Brock and
the MCU and he left behind a piece of
the Venom symbiote obviously setting up
the black suit coming into the MCU which
will then lead into Venom actually being
in the main Universe instead of this
embarrassing cousin that the Sony
franchise currently is I'm just playing
I actually like the Venom movies in in a
sadistic way yes I know they're rubbish
but but I like them anyway Marvel
originally had this big plan for how
they wanted to bring Tom Holland and his
Spider-Man and then slowly build up
towards the black suit however Sony
started off their venom franchise which
was disconnected from the MCU and this
caused a lot of trouble behind the
scenes from what I've been told Tom
Holland was meant to feature in it with
a brief Cameo but Marvel Studios pulled
a plug in it and said no way Holmes they
then did the new deal with Sony and one
of the stipulations was that the
franchises connect to the MCU which we
have seen play out so now foggy is
basically young to Venom symbiote and
put it in the MCU I haven't been told
this by anyone so don't go wild with it
but I'd love to see Tom Hardy brought
across at the end of Secret Wars with
the converging of the timelines like I
said I enjoyed the Venom movies in a
sadistic way and him being in the MCU
would probably help to strengthen those
firms with fikey at the helm either way
I have heard that the next Spider-Man
movie won't actually focus on the black
suit plotline and that they're saving it
for a film further down the line now in
the comics Spider-Man got his black suit
in the original Secret Wars storyline
this is disconnected from the big
Multiverse one that brings all the
timelines together but potentially they
could just end up combining them that's
purely speculation but the focus for
Spider-Man 4 is meant to be more of a
grounded level 1 similar Spider-Man
homecoming the homecoming of age story
allowed us to see basically a week in
the life of your friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man and it was more about Peter
navigating High School than taking on
world ending threats I really hope that
this means we get a payoff on that
post-credits scene that featured the
Scorpion because my man Mando has been
waiting in the wings too long we could
also use this to introduce black cat or
Gwen Stacy in the MCU and really the
possibilities are endless now you might
have read tweets a couple of weeks back
from Jacob battleland that were taken
out of context to make it look like he
didn't want a Payday basically the
reports led to him saying that he was
open to a Spider-Man 4 but that he
wasn't herbing for it lots of people
didn't read the full interview well it
is Twitter and they kind of flipped out
over this being like why'd you wanna
why'd you not want to give us more
Spider-Man movies Jacob that's all we
want
how about the full quote reveals what's
going on with it and he said I feel like
actors are the last people to know I
think that people assume that axes are
always hiding Secrets very sexy voice no
wonder you're the CEO of sex I promise
you we don't know anything but again if
it's the right place at the right time
with the right group of people that
we've been with I would say why not but
other than that whatever happens happens
really those decisions are up to the big
bosses the people who sign the checks
were open to the idea but we're not
hoping for it so yeah mate no need to
lose you on Twitter just calm down it's
just social media pay you eight dollars
so your tweets don't get buried and shut
the [ __ ] up anyway Sony have a lot on
their hands at the moment and expect to
see all their movies and characters
connecting with each other across a
number of mediums we have craving the
hunter now entering post-production
we're in the final weeks of filming on
Madame web and there's of course El
muerto the most hyped movie of all time
but what I'm looking forward to the most
is across the spider verse and I think
it's going to be a massive celebration
of the characters in more ways than the
first one they are really aiming to have
every single recognizable Spider-Man
feature in it and this will then thread
the seeds for the rest of the Multiverse
movies that are coming from the Marvel
staple Secret Wars is gonna be something
special too without being a lot of major
characters appearing in it I don't know
how they're actually going to keep it a
secret but yeah lots of things to look
forward to
and I am very hyped now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts so make sure
you comment below and let me know we are
in a competition right now and giving
away three copies of top gun Maverick on
the 15th of November and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video
don't say it's rubbish yet and if you do
I'll not pick you but we do pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners are the last one
on screen right now so that's you
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
now if you want something else to watch
make sure you check our breakdown
wakanda forever which will be linked on
the screen right now gone over the
entire thing from top to bottom so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for singing
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace